No, there was there's a certain spirit which uh I don't know if it's been dampened uh well certainly in some of the individuals involved, but hopefully not in the uh the youngsters.
But uh uh uh there's a certain spirit of discovery and uh uh the unknown, uh exploring the unknown that that that is just man, makes you wanna you know, wake up in the morning or in the night and jump in a lab and and see, you know, what will come forth and uh and this is a good thing.
This is a really good thing.
What advice would you have for someone, saying there's someone listening right now, there may be a junior, senior in high school.
They're interested in lasers, interested in optics and particularly they would love to one day be a holographer and create holograms.
W what advice would you have for them to choose that as a career path?
Oh, besides keeping the day job?
Yeah.
Um, I I say that with uh some regret.
Um well it's interesting, you know, in terms of of the distribution uh first of all th there there are some uh sort of meat and potatoes aspects of holography, which I'm sure your listeners are probably aware of the uh involving uh holographic non destructive testing and some uh engineering applications and nowadays the idea of creating h holograms that are simply templates for you know, creating nanostructures and things like that, these are the worlds in which these uh uh these kids are gonna be uh you know, um graduating into.
Um where the hologram is basically um a tool for uh any number of other things rather than uh let's say an art object per se or or a device for advertising.
Um there are so many more what I call these meat and potatoes applications of lottery, which are um uh holograms applied to different engineering challenges or biomedical engineering challenges and things like that where where, you know, we we have a result at the end of the line that is something other than aesthetic.
Some people say that, you know, art in the context of art, you know, some people say that it it it has to be absolutely useless to be fine art.
In other words have no other purpose to be fine art.
And there's a value to that.
There's a value to you know the you know to have a a sacred clown, you know, in the Hobi culture or whatever, you know, the the idea of having you know there's there's there's a reason for that sort of aesthetic.
Um but on the other hand uh if it's uh something where you want to for sure absolutely positively make money um and a living at it uh then then perhaps some of the so called meat and potato applications are or is Charles Vest still the the president of of MIT?
I I don't have a clue.
Okay, because at one point he was and I think we should all be proud of that.
He's of course a holographer he published uh holographic interferometry like the Bible event many years ago.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Where there's news.
And uh well he was I believe uh instrumental with Steve Benton and say it's he's probably been uh uh very supportive of the uh spatial imaging group up there.
Oh yeah and of course the c the the acquisition of the Museum of Holography's collection.
Yes.
Uh uh really from the depths and throes of uh of uh of being dispersed to the four corners of I don't know if you go over that kind of history with one of your holo talks but but there was a point in which museum holography's collection was going to be uh dispersed uh in in in not a good way and uh and Dr.
Benton and and Charles Fest w pivotal in and securing it for the MIT Museum, which your listeners can always go look at when in Boston which is nice.
Yeah.
I I'm just so surprised that in a metropolitan area the size of New York City that there's no museum of philography anymore.
I just you know, I'm just dumbfounded with that.
Well, you know, this year is there, you know, greater curiosity, you know.
And I mean I was on Eastman Kodak's website, uh the museum that is Eastman House's website, and I've been there in person.
It's wonderful.
But uh if you go on the website and you look at the history of photographic systems and you go backward, um you'll see a camera I was looking at a couple months ago.
It's uh made in 1852, it was the first one I could find that was 3D stereo camera made of you know brass and wood and glass and funky beautiful looking thing, and and taking three D pictures back in eighteen fifty two if I recall correctly.
And so now here we are a hundred and fifty years precisely later, and you don't go into uh any everybody's house and see, oh, there's you know a stereogram of the grandkids, you know.
I'm not even talking holograms now.
I'm just talking about stereophotography, a perfectly viable, wonderful imaging system for 3D that anyone can do with any camera.
You don't need a stereo camera and you just take two pictures as your audience might know, you know, slightly offset views.
And um uh so here's a perfectly good three-dimensional imaging system, 150 years old, and yet has not thoroughly permeated uh uh you know the culture.
And so um of course we have, you know, three D IMAX and still we have View Masters and all that, but I'm talking about something where people enjoy it among themselves and shoot their own.
So if we have a hundred and fifty years of stereography is fully, fully integrated into the average person's home, uh then you know, w w what is to say uh would you say about you know the holography and and when and if that will happen.
So so I scratch my head along with the next guy figuring out uh trying to figure out w w why isn't there a hologram in every home, you know, and a stereogram in every garage.
I mean it's wonderful, and now of course it's uh cheap.
I read a brilliant article by Andrew Pepper, uh about holography and architecture, and um uh uh I'm sure if you do a search for that you'll find it on the web.
It's a really, really good article.
Uh just a couple of days ago, really about a week ago, and uh and he mentions in it uh that some of the expectations that were created in the early days uh caused uh and this is a terrible paraphrasing because he's very eloquent about it.
Uh but uh uh it caused uh in the consumer uh you know, the p general public's mind, you know, this kind of expectation that maybe overshadowed the reality to a point where this is why there's a sort of deflated, oh well, you know.
And uh uh but I remember there were years that went by where we would say to each other among holographers that, you know, next year, you know, is gonna be the big one, you know, and then next year it's gonna be the and then on for a decade.
And here we are with gray hair.
Yeah, and um well, of course, uh you know, holograms have permeated the uh environment.
Uh for gosh sakes I've got I've seen 'em as litter uh these days.
I was in a parking lot of a Denny's uh a couple of years ago and and they were just like a little you know litter.
And uh which is sad.
But uh there they are.
And um uh uh no, it's it's a period I I I would call uh you know the chotchkefication, you know, holography.
Well it's happening big in education, but once again that's almost like we're using holography as a tool.
Oh I'm glad to hear that.
I did not know that.
Oh, absolutely.
Full bone courses uh you can graduate as a the doctor in holography.
Well no, not to that point.
We're talking about uh uh supplementary uh classroom activities and science and physics and things of that nature.
To the elementary or mainly high school.
Mainly high school.
Yeah.
You know, and uh some of the projects that I've been involved with with disadvantaged youth seems to be uh taking off too.
Oh that's wonderful.
Yeah.
Duvall County in Florida.
Actually, I'll be down in Florida in November.
You're kidding.
Yeah, too.
Oh we gotta get together.
Yeah, I don't know how far Duval it's in Jacksonville, I don't know how far that is.
That's gotta be closer than where you are now.
Well, absolutely it's closer.
Yeah, yeah.
So uh I'll I'll give you a buzz uh before I head down for that.
So you're gonna make holograms with the kids?
Uh meeting with a few of the community colleges and uh Deval County School District.
I was down there uh one time before there's a a teacher down there that is involved with communication technology and he has a wonderful holography program for Oh, this is great.
I'm so happy to hear that.
Yeah, so uh that's starting to be mirrored in other areas as well.
If I can help, just let me know.
That's yeah.
Uh in fact I will let him know, you know, that you're so close close by.
I I really enjoy that.
In fact, more than anything, I I have I uh I learned so much when I started teaching that I never expected to learn so much uh when I started teaching at night.
Yeah.
That's that's most actually of what I did for many years.
Uh huh.
You know, through museums and you know, science museums and stuff.
Put food on the table, you know.
But this isn't my interview, this is yours.
So let's uh let's get back to uh I I know you had mentioned earlier that uh you had sent an email, you know, listing a few of the things that you want to cover.
I did go back into the email program.
I didn't see that.
So if there's anything.
I worked hard on that, frankly.
I know, you probably did.
No, actually there's nothing there unless it's something that I didn't click on or whatever, but uh uh as of two thirty I wasn't able to find it.
Oh, I see here it has an odd uh title.
I'm looking at it now.
What does it say?
It doesn't say anything about how I can enlarge my breasts or anything, does it?
No, no.
Because I get a lot of those.
Okay, I can look at it and use it as a as a reference here.
Go ahead, Doc.
Um uh for the students out there who started to make holograms, uh I make a note of the importance of uh optical schematics and triple checking yourself.
The idea that whatever you're doing, make yourself a little sketch, it doesn't have to be elaborate.
Uh whether you're using continuous wave heanies or or diodes or whatever.
Make a little sketch of what you're doing, uh make your measurements, you know, a little tape measure centimeter measure like a tailor's measure and and uh take some notes because you'll find from time to time you'll uh you'll do something really neat and you'll want to repeat that experiment.
So no matter how simple they are, uh some kind of optical schematic of what you've done.
And as far as triple checking yourself, well, it's just a good way to save uh save on materials.
Yeah.
Measure measure twice, cut once.
Yeah, well I like to measure three times.
Because then you can go two out of three.
Um that was something I wanted to to bring out.
Um and uh uh well um Take your time.
Yeah.
Oh, you cut out the blank spaces?
Uh no, we're all right.
I mean, you know.
Well, it's interesting.
Um I've got uh uh one of the reasons for some of these somewhat you know, sort of campy or kitschy or sort of silly things that I've done, uh like the you know, smelling hologram and stuff, uh and the macaroni piece, I guess people know.
Um it's just that we take ourselves so darn seriously.
Um so it's important to to lighten up.
Yeah.
And uh and so that's why I like doing sometimes uh uh you know, somewhat silly things in holograms because it's just all so darn serious.
Uh by the time you know you split your beams and you get all your other stuff right and you pay the rent and everything.
Bam, uh, you know, it's hard to uh to uh to add some levity to the situation.
So like every hologram doesn't have to uh describe the meaning of life.
No, but if you you can send me a copy of that particular one, I'd like to see that if you've got it seems like a lot of them try.
Interesting.
Yeah I'd I'd love to read some of the descriptions not just with holography but anything in art, you know, as far as what the artist was trying to convey.
Right.
And uh I get lost sometimes to tell you the truth.
I just get up in the morning and do a day's worth of work, that type of person, you know so I'll read these descriptions and well it's funny because actually I did make a note that perhaps the uh perhaps the uh the ultimate impact of uh of holography will be you know the so called holographic paradigm the the idea that you know inform Hey you know I'm sorry I I I don't know how to disable that.
Should I answer that Frank?
Uh that may be the big contract.
Why don't you answer what you get back to me I'll put this on it's a funny guy hold on.
Hello.
Hey okay we're we're we're eating up megabytes aren't we that's okay.
Are we going straight to the hard drive or are you going to actual tape or what do you think I go I go right to the hard drive.
I also have an optical recorder too but I And we're rolling now?
Yes we are.
Oh I apologize.
Oh that's okay for what?
Uh well eating up gigs, I don't know.
This is just an interval not disabling the uh call waiting I suppose you call it what I started to say was that um i it it took me a while to figure this out but perhaps the ultimate impact of holography uh will be completely invisible on wait list.
Mm-hmm.
Have nothing to do with making holograms and tell you whether uh uh welds are separating or or selling uh toothpaste or uh uh you know pop musicians and all that good stuff.
Um mainly uh just the principle of holography as applied to our understanding how information is dispersed through universes is uh a paradigm that's been kicked around for quite a while and there are whole books on it as I'm sure some of your audience is aware of.
Uh but it took me a while to figure out that that was really important stuff versus uh all the actual hard applications of holography.
Uh you know hard copy applications where you're actually making something.
The concept is uh is maybe more more lasting and more powerful than anything we can actually do with the medium.
So uh um this is interesting.
This is a very interesting aspect that again as I said it's weightless and invisible but very much real.
Yeah.
Yes, very much.
Very much.
In the old days, you know when I was first making holograms I felt that I was at ground zero and that all these people, you know, when with ropes and incense and everything, they were that were talking about this stuff back in the mid seventies it seemed like, you know, well what the heck did they know about holograms.
Mm-hmm.
And then all of a sudden 'cause they were adopting the hologram as their uh you know their paradigm for explaining different various things.
But then in time after I did a little research and I met a few individuals I I started uh who were on the subject um I I started realizing that this is really powerful stuff and it's way, way uh important.
Yeah you m back back with uh Carl Prime and uh Oh yeah.
I spoke with I've spoken with him Yeah and uh David Bone.
Yeah.
I think Ken Wilbur did a wonderful book on that.
I think it's called The Holographic Paradigm and Other Paradoxes as well.
Mm-hmm.
No, they're very they're very interesting and of course for ancient for those in the audience who are unfamiliar with what we're talking about, because that's possible.
Yeah.
Um uh there uh the idea that you take a hologram break it into little pieces and see the entire scenario in every little piece because of the dispersed information storage aspect of holography that you can actually break a hologram piece off and see the whole scene that was pictured in uh you know Frank sometimes you and I forget about stuff that people are unaware of that yeah when they're first coming to this um and uh uh in any event it's one of the most powerful aspects of uh of of how different holography is from photography the fact that you can break off a little piece of a hologram and see the whole scene pictured in that little piece and uh because the hologram's like a window into that scenario and and uh so this has led to corollaries with um at least ancient eastern philosophical tenets that uh that suggest that uh that information about everything is everywhere and transcends space and time and you simply have to get in the right mindset uh to access that information but it nonetheless fills all space and time and so it's very interesting uh having uh a a hard copy version of example yeah you used to call point toable example phenomenon the famous quotes for that is the brain is a hologram interpreting a holographic universe I believe is that's a good one that's a good one.
Well it would make sense that if you were going to build an antenna for something that it would have to uh correspond uh to the waveform that you're trying to receive.
Yes, exactly.
Good thinking.
Yeah.
Sharp.
Um totally unrelated but may not be.
Okay.
And I've always wanted to ask this you you do so much commercial work and I have to phrase this properly for the show, but uh do you get do you ever get a lot of calls for any adult work?
You know considering the the explosion of adult material on the internet.
Sure.
And it's mostly visual.
Yeah, the two main reasons for trees dying uh in the world being cut down uh for paper are uh uh pornography and uh computer manuals.
Those are the two biggest eaters of paper uh of trees uh right now on Earth.
But seriously folks, um well once in a while let's call them erotic, you know that that happens from time to time.
Yeah.
Uh the big the w the fellow who used to be sort of a king of all that sort of thing was out on the West Coast, his name was uh Peter Claudius and in the early days of multiplex he was the guy who explored that I think more than anyone.
There's even a snapshot of him with his so called follow blow machine uh in on my website if you wander among the holaroids okay you'll see Peter standing there with his uh hand on one of the knobs so to speak.
Okay.
They're knobs, they're door knobs and that it's perfectly uh perfectly clean.
Yeah.
Did you ever do any of the um three hundred and sixty uh integrals?
Oh my god yeah oh what a wonderful format sure absolutely I think I produced the first cyclic one in which there was no beginning or end.
And it was fun to explore that uh back pre you know the digital domain uh it was a portrait of a guy named Ramdas.
Oh okay yeah and so I filmed him uh sitting uh cross legged in my studio on the turntable and as he rotated around to a frontal view uh we stopped the turntable and I did a slow zoom into his eyes and then and then uh uh then you noticed this thing was appearing in a sort of third eye area and his eyes faded out and as his eyes faded out this thing faded up and uh you re and it was you realize it was spinning the circular design, this mandala pattern and it was spinning and you were zooming away from it.
And just by about the time that you had a full view of the full Mondala spinning in the middle of the three sixty, this image of this guy sitting in full lotus position from seen from behind starts fading up from the center of the mandala and then the mandala fades out and you're back to uh him arcing around and looking you in the eye again.
So it's a hologram that had no real beginning or end and it was an interesting experiment I did with uh Linwood Dunn, uh did the optical out in Hollywood and starting to apply Hollywood effects to uh to holographic stereograms.
It was kind of seemed like a no brainer at the time and and so basically the tail of the A element of his portrait was faded and dissolved into the b head of the B element which was uh the mandala and then at the tail of the B element it was faded and dissolved back in so that's the way the the into a so that's the way the the film was prepared and it basically it's nothing it's an ancient thing in Hollywood, but it was kinda new to holography to go through that kind of a optical handstand to produce the origination materials.
And I'm trying to think of who printed a uh hologram.
Oh, okay, yeah, but that's you're looking at six out of a thousand and eighty frames.
Mm-hmm.
It's again.
Yes.
Anything else you want to add to the interview more?
Um well nothing occurs to me right off the uh you know, it's it's one of these things I'm sure when I hang up I'll say, Oh man, I could have told them about that.
But um yeah, I guess that we could talk just for a minute about about, you know, uh when I first got into holography I realized that some of the the absolute best people making holograms technically were uh totally uh uh unaware of what art made an art image mm-hmm and all that.
So I kinda wanted to bridge that that that right there was seemed to be the challenge at the get go was to be able to technically execute these things that with with some aesthetic that was, you know, powerful as well as opposed to just like, well here's a hologram of my uh you know, salt and pepper shaker or my forks or whatever.
And uh and all and while it is very intriguing to see a three dimensional image of uh of an object uh that may not be present anymore or you know in the holographic image that's very intriguing.
There's more to be done with a medium than simply three dimensionally uh capturing things that you can imagine in the first place.
Or even capture in other ways three dimensionally.
And uh there was a fellow by the name of MC Escher, who's a very famous uh artist uh I'm sure you've people in your audience have seen his work familiar with his work.
And in one of his books he talks about uh the um uh approaches to infinity is what he calls it.
It's a little monograph, it's like a page and a half long in the beginning of one of those famous Escher books.
And he calls in in approaches to infinity he describes how uh when he was originally schooled as a draftsman his his main task was trying to make that eye brain hand connection and and convey that which his mind's eye could grasp onto paper.
And that was what he had to learn at first.
Well once he got that down real well, um uh this sort of kinda bored him and he started uh imagining thinking about w well how can I convey things that the mind's eye can't grasp, such as infinity.
And this began like a thirty, forty year uh um effort in so many various works that I'm sure many of the viewers have seen, uh uh uh in which he tried to convey this concept of infinity.
He says to himself, Well I'd need a piece of paper of infinite size so that's not gonna work.
Somehow in a small area I'm gonna have to evoke that feeling and and that became his pursuit and um so I mention this in the context of holography only because um uh we all like for instance you have a hologram of some puppy dogs or a hologram of uh you know a clown or whatever.
We can all kind of imagine what a clown looks like in three D or puppy dog or whatever uh salt and pepper shakers.
Um it's the stuff that we can't imagine in three D that I find so interesting uh uh uh to use holography as a medium for.
That's why I personally I'm I'm I'm partial to abstracts uh abstract images.
Just the beauty of the color and the light and the purity of the color uh that one can do in the kinetics that you can apply.
I've I've done quite a number of holograms like that but um uh this actually my favorite stuff is is the non representational holograms where they're not necessarily representing a three dimensional thing but the medium is just used as a fluid way to paint with light that moves.
Yes.
And uh and then it wouldn't be impossible to do with any other medium.
Yeah exactly exactly whereas a good stereogram of um you know the puppy dogs or whatever uh it's pretty much the same thing.
Um so so that's something that maybe people can be uh uh launched into some of your students are uh prac early practitioners what have you well maybe any older practitioners um but uh uh I enjoy that aspect of holography that you can that you can approach uh the visualization of things that cannot be um imagined and uh it's is is I think more interesting.
I've done a couple of holograms like that.
And I think that that's that's cool stuff, you know.
We're like big game fishing in the in the you know, in the dark void of pure research, you know.
And then stuff pops up.
Yeah.
When you're not in pursuit of uh of applied science or or art in particular, stuff stuff does show up.
Dr.
Gabor invented holography, discovered it if you will, uh by so called accident, some say, in that he was really trying to improve two dimensional imaging technology of electron microscopy.
Yes.
So uh he inadvertently or serendipitously discovered a three dimensional imaging medium.
So my contention is that what will a holographer in route uh one day in route to trying to improve holography, uh the three dimensional imaging technology of Halarve discover by so called accident or serendipitously.
So it's that the hope of that next uh window into something that we've never seen before that may show up and this is why I said earlier, uh whether they're fifteen or they're sixty years old, it makes no difference.
Uh well my oldest student has been seventy-two years old and my youngest student is eight years old.
And uh I I don't think that um that age has anything to do with it.
Uh it's just a matter of paying real close attention.
Yeah.
Maybe time travel will be the holography of the future.
Who knows?
Well I think time travel and and then so far fetched, but I'm sure holography is far fish at one time as well.
Just as far fetched.
Well, you know, there's there's a wacky uh wacky uh directions that things are going in terms of projection technology, you know, uh uh uh direct right to retina, I think is is is has a big future.
It already exists, of course.
Uh where you pop on the glasses and the the little diodes are writing writing the images on your retinas, but it appears as a giant three dimensional image in space in front of you.
Uh so that's that already exists.
Um while it hasn't been made super popular, they're you know, under defense contracts for those things and not sure you can actually run out and buy one, but they're they're they exist for some years now.
We're we're you you don't require a giant screen at all.
The glasses are actually projecting writing the image and rewriting it onto your retins directly.
Yeah.
So I think other directions for for this sort of thing for you know may uh it may evolve into something else.
I don't know about the time travel part, right?
That's uh that's very ambitious.
Where can someone see your work?
Do you have anything exhibited anywhere across the country right now?
Yeah, there's some stuff I know that I believe still in like for instance in Canada, I think they still have a giant Dizzy over at the uh at the uh Ontario Science Museum.
Okay.
And uh uh up until recently there was some stuff in uh I I don't really know where all the stuff is.
I have a gallery down in Florida.
I have I maintain a gallery down here now.
Uh-huh.
And uh tell the listeners about that 'cause I'm sure there's some people in Florida.
Oh, sure.
Well if anyone can just go to the website, you know, Diamond Images dot com and then and then give me a ring and say, Hey, uh I'd love to come over 'cause it's not like open to the public in general.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um I I set up a first gallery of hologram south in New York here back in seventy five, I think it was, and ran that for about twelve years.
And so that was pretty neat.
Uh that was actually a place where you could come in and see the work of holographers from all over the world really.
It's not just my own, uh for about twelve years and um uh maybe a hundred holograms at any given time on display.
Yeah.
And that's always been fun and uh still maintain a collection, but uh and from time to time do uh, you know, tr uh not a traveling show per se, but a show that can travel.
Mm-hmm.
Um and uh Well you've certainly done a lot of work and and you're really uh out there as far as continuing with uh projects all the time.
Yeah, it's amazing how some of these things, you know, you have to kind of stick uh stick with your dreams because uh some of them take a long time to come to fruition.
Yeah.
I guess you just have to find your place.
I found my niche I think with the uh amateurs and hobbyists and education end which uh I think some people uh in the early days were uh interested in the education, but I don't think there was a lot of interest in anybody being an amateur or hobbyist, but I saw that as an an opportunity for uh growth.
Oh, it's wonderful.
I I still insist, you know, I know I'm repeating myself, but uh but but it it's not necessarily from academics and from professional scientists that the developments come from.
I mean didn't the guys who developed Codachrome, aren't they musicians, you know?
Um so uh it's it's really uh uh I expect um the innovations to come from the outside as much as from the inside of the so-called scientific establishment.
Absolutely.
And that's going to happen with an amateur uh who is paying real close attention.
Okay.
Well, Mark, I want to thank you for taking this time to uh talk.
It's been a great interview, and I'm sure people appreciate you taking the time as well to uh come on and talk about holography.
There's not too many outlets out there, you know, where someone can uh you know come on and uh listen to somebody talk about something that they enjoy.
So uh thank you very much.
Oh, it's been my pleasure.
And if I grab uh one of the pictures of your holograms, would it be okay to put it on the whole?
Oh sure, people steal stuff on my site all the time.
Yeah, I know.
All right, well Mark, thank you very much.
I'll send I'll send you an email when the uh show's getting ready to go up, okay.